cette fois plus de résidus de certains
pesticides dans les framboises trois
fois plus dans les bleuets c'est ce que
propose santé canada dans le cadre de
deux consultations publiques pour moi
j'ai pas un besoin mais pas du tout au
contraire on essaie plutôt de diminuer
l'incompréhension est totale chez les
producteurs de bleuets du québec qui
misent de plus en plus sur le biologique
et crade m'a surpris parce qu'on n'a pas
tendu par les pas tout
parson connaître les produits l'a fait
la demande
et pourquoi les deux produits en
question sont le métalaxyl un fongicide
qui sert à combattre la pourriture des
racines et le sulfate à flores un
insecticide qui permet de tuer les
pucerons et les punaises pour les
bleuets santé canada propose de faire
passer de trois à dix parties par
million la concentration permise de
métalaxyl et de 0,7 à deux parties par
million le seuil autorisé pour le
sulfate sa flore pour les framboises la
concentration de métal axe il grimperait
de 0,2 à 1,5 parties par million il n'y
a aucun conducteur qui demandent ce
l'association qui représente les
producteurs de framboises pense que la
demande provient des fabricants de
pesticides qui souhaiteraient un
rehaussement des seuils pour exporter
leurs produits plus facilement une
perspective inquiétante selon elle
puisque certains pays comme le mexique
ou le chili pourrait profiter de
l'occasion pour écouler davantage de
framboises au canada c'est à nous à dire
aux pays exportateurs va regarder si
vous voulez quant au canada mais nous
nos producteurs aussi nombreux que vous
devez suivre ses mailles normes le
suivre lui peu importe qui est à
l'origine un
que ce soit les compagnies que ce soit
d'autres pays
le monde de santé canada c'est de
protéger la santé de sa population le
premier ministre trudeau se fait
rassurant on se base sur la science pour
garder les gens en sécurité mais on
compte aussi écouter les experts les
citoyens qui ont souvent des
préoccupations à ce niveau là
l'entreprise corte vaki vendu s'il faut
que la flore au canada assure qu'elle
n'a pas formulé de demande pour une
hausse des seuils pour sa part santé
canada n'a pas été en mesure de répondre
à nos questions messieurs levier bachar
réseau canada montréal